[Music]
wo no come
on look at
[Music]
him what are we doing you think in
another life I could have been a
bird what do you mean like
reincarnation I don't
know I think
it's
woo say I'm a
bird no don't do it say I'm a bird stop
it it
now say
it you're a
[Music]
bird now say you're a bird
too if you're a bird I'm a bird
[Music]
[Applause]
no
Why didn't you right
me
why it wasn't over for me I waited for
you for 7 years now it's too late I
wrote you 365
letters I wrote you every day for a
year you wrote me
yes it wasn't
over still isn't
over
it's about security what is that
supposed to mean money what are you talk
he's got a lot of money now I hate you
you bastard if you leave here I hate
you pay attention to anything that's
been happening I guess not I think I
must have misread all of those signals
yes you
did you're
bored you're bored you know it you
wouldn't be here if there wasn't
something missing arog son of a
would you just stay with be stay
with you what for look at us we're
already fighting well that's what we do
we fight you tell me when I'm being an
arrogant son of a and I tell you
when you're being a pain in the ass
which you are 99% of the time I'm not
afraid to hurt your
feelings they have like a two second
rebound rate and you're back doing the
next pain in the ass
thing so what so it's not going to be
easy it's going to be really hard and
we're going to have to work at this
every day but I want to do that because
I want you I want all of you forever you
and me every day will you do something
for
me please you just picture your life for
me 30 years from now 40 years from now
what's it look like if it's with that
guy go go I lost you once I think I
could do it again if I thought it's what
you really
wanted but don't you take the easy way
out what easy way there is no easy way
no matter what I do somebody gets hurt
would you stop thinking about what
everyone
wants stop thinking about what I want
what he wants what your parents want
what do you
want what do you want it's not that
simple what do you
want God damn it what do you
want I have to
go
my dearest
Ally couldn't sleep last night because I
know that it's over between
us I'm not bitter anymore because I know
that what we had was
real and if in some distant place in the
future we see each other in our new
lives I'll smile at you with joy and
remember how we spent a summer beneath
the trees
learning from each other and growing in
love the best love is the kind that
awakens the soul that makes us reach for
more that plants a fire in our hearts
and brings peace peace to our
minds and that's what you've given
me that's what I'd hope to give to you
forever I love you I'll be seeing you no
do you
think that our love can create
Miracles yes I
do that's what brings you back to me
each
time
do you think I
love could take us away
together I think our love can do
anything we want it
to
love
you I love you
Al good
night good night
I'll be seeing
you